(bright music)
Welcome back.
Our next guest is a Wildflower who lives a dual life.
She's a sanitation worker for the city of New York by day,
and a beauty pageant contestant in her free time.
When you see her, you will understand why.
She's from Staten Island, New York;
please welcome the clean queen, Nicole Doz.
(audience cheers)
Hi, thank you so much for having me.
Thank you so much for coming here.
What a polarity, multifaceted life you live.
You keep the city clean,
you're really passionate about this.
Tell me why, and how you go about it.
Yeah, so I started as a sanitation worker,
which means that, yeah,
I was physically picking up garbage every day,
so that would be almost approximately 12 tons a day,
if not more, and I also drive a street sweeper.
What was the catalyst?
So my dad is actually a sanitation worker also,
and I really just wanted to be able to support myself.
And I knew it was a male dominated field,
but I said, if they can do it, why can't I?
I want to support myself,
I want to be able to stand on my own two feet in this city,
and what better way than doing this?
Not only is it male dominated,
even when it comes to the uniforms,
you kind of had to struggle there, right?
Oh, yeah.
So even now, there's only about 200 women,
and there's about 7,000 sanitation workers.
And at the time when I first started working,
there were no female clothing,
so I actually had male pants tailored to me
in order just to go to work every single day.
Thankfully we've come very far,
so we have female pants now,
I get to wear my lady pants to work,
but yeah, it was a struggle
that I wasn't necessarily prepared for at the beginning.
My God, I'm so in awe
(audience applauds)
of everything
that you're saying.
I'd also like to learn from you,
because we get told these really,
sometimes scary facts about recycling.
What can we do to recycle better?
How does it function?
What do you need from us?
Please teach us.
Just to be vigilant.
There's a lot of things that can be recycled
that you wouldn't necessarily assume could be,
but on the flip side of that,
there are a lot of things that need
to be recycled in very specific ways.
Okay, we have some examples over here.
In my personal house, I want to learn from you.
Teach me.
So we have here,
we've got our metal.
This is tin foil,
and a lot of people would naturally assume
that it's garbage;
you've got your food on it, things like that.
I would suggest, rinse it off, you can recycle this,
this would be considered metal.
Really?
Absolutely.
Right in your plastic and metal.
How important is cleaning a vessel for the recycling bin?
I would absolutely suggest
to rinse off your products as much as you can,
because all of that organic matter on the inside,
sometimes we're not able to take it
if it's contaminated for recycling,
so always do your best
to try to clear things out of it.
Like a jar of peanut butter, for example,
clean that all out.
But you know, whatever you can do is always helpful.
Okay, next?
Yes, so we have here, right over here,
we have a container of milk.
A lot of people would assume
that because it's made of a cardboard type of material,
that it's paper.
It's not; this is also recycled with your plastic and metal,
because on the inside, it's lined with plastic.
So that's why you recycle this with your plastic and metal.
Okay, okay.
So, carton, but treated as plastic.
Yes.
Okay.
Recyclable plastic.
What is this?
So that is tissue paper.
You hear the word paper,
so you would automatically assume it's recyclable.
This is something we like to call wish-cycling:
something we really, really hope is recyclable,
but unfortunately, it's not.
Because of the way it's made,
this is something we're not able to recycle,
so that's something that would go in the trash.
What are these?
I mean, I know what they are,
(audience members chuckle)
but why are they here?
These can be recycled with your paper, and they should be,
because cardboard is so easily recyclable.
Okay, so these go in the recycling,
not your little trash can
next to your--
They go in the recycling.
All right, well, thank you.
I did not know that, and that is going to change my life.
What are these guys doing?
So, another wish-cycling item.
They're glass, so we're automatically going to assume
they're gonna go into your plastic, metal, glass bin,
but they don't, unfortunately, that's trash.
What's the difference?
Different types of materials of glass.
It's just particulars as far as recycling goes.
All right, well, this has been honestly so educational
for me,
(audience applauds)
I really, really, really, appreciate it.
Now sit back down for one more minute.
I want to ask you, as we close out our discussion,
give me the PM beauty queen perspective.
What is that life like?
That is my glamorous side, and I love every bit of it.
I've been competing in pageants since I was about 18.
It took me a long time until I finally won one,
it took about six years or so,
but I love it because I get
to promote something that's important to me,
and environmentalism
and living a zero waste lifestyle is important to me,
and it's really fun that I've been able
to mesh together these two really different lifestyles
into something really wonderful.
(audience applauds)
You know, that song like "I'm Every Woman"?
I think it was written about you.
Thank you.
Thank you so much
for coming on this show
(audience applauds)
and being who you are,
and teaching what you teach,
and being the example.
I'm mesmerized by you.
Thank you so much, Nicole.
Thank you.
(bright music)